should I pick cannabis or abduction Noah
yeah abduction
[Music]
which one I don't know you tell me
okay let's do Oh
Dula DAF King kyun corner cough cough
lol LaDonna
they were laid off at time patent if
half of do for and Jeff okay cannibalism
it is I just gotta make sure I'm
recording yeah I am
I have not surely forgotten at all I
still remember a lot of things about my
childhood about my life there are just
some things that I cannot recall as if
they were covered behind the shadows I
have an epic movie cinema voice let's go
No cannibalism I have not forgotten at
all I still remember parts of it I'm not
sure about my name and why I'm in this
mansion I am or why I can't do that
voice along it hurts my throat with dust
and cold sweat however do remember that
this mansion blocks a man above all of
it yeah I got it did you got it
not know great genius has ever existed
without some touch of maddest
I guess I'm rich ash
this sound sounds exactly like you know
the cracking in when you're going insane
in amnesia doesn't it I think it's all
free Wow
love already come on he's so slow
I wanna play baby it's not working it's
not responding that's not good that's
how it works
hello
ha
[Music]
what am I doing here oh pretty great
not anymore
I gave though let's move this to a
jammer
and that's before we do anything else
Herbert's
okay so we're following Herbert's
cussing from the original amnesia story
I guess I don't know why otherwise
whatever I think his name was Herbert
Herbert long for my cousin William has
right today's visit was very unexpected
but I always liked Billy
I know what he's talking about right
William round has a weird voice we
always talk to one another while the
other thing of course he was tired of
the trip and we got no chance to talk
today he ate and went bed tomorrow we
will have a grand conversation you know
what that means but sex anyway okay that
was weird
let's just make sure I yeah see any box
you got to lose
oh man he's pretty creepy
sorry I gotta turn up the volume and go
much better ah I'm feeling nice yeah
whoa that was officially creepy sound I
didn't know it was from my apartment or
somewhere else
holy cow
creepy sounds no mannequins I don't
trust you
I don't trust bag of potatoes either
whoa whoa whoa what was that
who's playing the piano not cool
this is really weird shut up ya know
[Music]
stop playing it's annoying okay room key
of [ __ ] cook I mean what
which way whatever
sweater nice and cozy fire it's like I I
also keep a big freaking stone brick in
my closet because why not
another no but I guess dear Herbert now
you read this I'm not here anymore
because I believe to my I have left even
I know that much my mother and brother
need help I whatever and drop key in
Cabin me hope it not melt
oh he's [ __ ] may it make me again
something it's I thought I was being
like clever and [ __ ] but apparently he
just spells bad it's supposed to be the
character aren't I smart it's a nice boy
yeah Seraphin I had a conversation oh we
know I'm sure you enjoyed it about the
present present about the future
surprising when I mentioned experiment
he was shocked at least twenty degree I
was prepared for of course I did I
mention the most horrid part was still I
think that in time he will accept my
experiments I just got to make sure i
diluted everything
I don't know why they won't give you a
lantern in the mod it's so annoying
I came from here right
[Music]
so greenish it holy cow sledgehammer
like use this against a bro
sweet tinderboxes breaks pause
nothing else bread
Oh God is so dark
oh here's the door of course it's locked
maybe I can use this holy cow I'm a
freakin yes sitting Pete Jesus oh man oh
that scared me today I gave a vexing to
all dogs and now the Masters best one is
missing of course mattress expects me
but I'm not to blame even though I
stolen the spare key in his room I think
that was a clue actually I think I
should read that again oh come on
Matthew stolen a spare key to his room
so he should have a key here somewhere I
guess I don't know I'm just saying that
it's all a key maybe I'm a freaking
genius okay so let's go to Herbert's
dream and you are one Shakespeare hell
of a guy
what are you doing oh I see
at least I'd given my favor well
I'll pack that was like the water
monster
what is in here
tinderbox
come on everything is like wait all
right move the bad
okay there's nothing in here I guess we
can move on yeah hey what's up with this
room
I like the level designer actually the
brick [ __ ] yeah Oh Tina Mott's
I thought it was gonna be a door here ah
oh I can't breathe that a crime I could
make that apparently
okay maybe this works
nope
I'm sorry came from it's going tinderbox
might it's fine
is that
oh it's like a cross
how many bear works here no I need to
find her bathroom how do I know which
one is nervous
I wish there was a big sign saying her
final nervous room shut up Daniel
all right move to everything
whoa whoa Oh what the heck
Oh presents nom-nom-nom lantern
sweet cheese her Birds long for day two
when I woke up my eldest servant Bob
told me about two very odd things first
during the night someone stole a notable
amount of meat during from my celery
secondly in blah blah blah missing dogs
the first case is odd enough but the
second is very unsettling first suspect
my new [ __ ] I mean cook at least about
the first case but when we search the
kitchen and his room we found nothing he
could not have eaten at all during night
either I promised a reward for anyone
finds the one responsible to crime I did
not change channels to talk the weather
in jail because I was strolling the
forest looking for my job till the late
night
I don't think that was any clue maybe it
was I don't know
I have oil sweet oh man it's so much
nicer with a ladder
okay we only found a key and I don't
really know what he got leads to it's
got oh man
he's gotta just try every door again
where's that song
what's doing that
I love my lantern I have you been here
I love my lantern I love it so much
we've been in here - there's only one
door and it's here so it's got to be
this one
what don't you dare see
okay
okay it's got to be this one yeah
[Music]
break stuff it's not badass
and I have to end it see you